why did casino billionaire Sheldon
Adelson recently hosts an emergency
summit of pro-israel activists in Las
Vegas to strategize on how to stop the
growing movement on college campuses to
boycott divest from and sanction the
State of Israel the BDS movement is a
call from Palestinian civil society to
impose nonviolent measures to get Israel
to comply with its obligations under
international law and end its denial of
Palestinian rights the movement is
loosely based off of South Africa's
anti-apartheid movement in the 1970s and
80s now ten years on BDS is making some
serious headway across college campuses
and in particular after Israel's summer
2014 war on Gaza more and more student
associations are urging their
universities to stop investing in
companies that operate in Israeli
occupied Palestinian territories in the
University of California system alone
seven different student bodies passed
divestment resolutions and across the
Atlantic in the UK the National Union of
Students recently voted to ally itself
with the BDS campaign something Prime
Minister Netanyahu lashed out against
the boycott Israel but they refused to
boycott Isis that tells you everything
you want to know about the BDS movement
in the past
Israel dismissed BDS as a trivial
movement but now the country and its
allies in the US are a bit more panicked
and are launching full-on attacks Nan
Yahoo said he's preparing an offensive
against the boycott efforts calling on
both the left and right within his
government to stand together to send off
the attackers and in the u.s. one of the
main anti BDS battlegrounds has been the
campuses themselves a new anonymous web
site called canary mission is naming and
shaming pro-palestine college activists
with the intention of blacklisting them
from jobs today college campuses are
filled its anti-semitic and
anti-american radicals waving
Palestinian flags and plan
and screaming apartheid and murderer but
BDS activists say their tactics aren't
anti-semitic but rather against the
state of Israel's policies even so a
recent report shows numerous incidents
of students and faculty being accused of
anti-semitism or terrorism based solely
on their criticism of Israeli policy
beyond American college campuses anti
BDS efforts have included legislation
Illinois South Carolina Indiana and
Tennessee have all passed anti BDS bills
and in Washington DC bipartisan bills
and amendments that would counter BDS
have found their way to the House floor
but the backlash hasn't stopped the BDS
movement from claiming recent victories
including on the cultural level like
when singer Lauryn Hill cancelled her
show in Israel in May after pressure
from BDS activists so given all the
recent triumphs and the efforts to stop
them can the BDS movement achieve what
peace negotiations have long failed to